your latest screenwriting credit is long
gone by
and you you share credit with co
co-writing on that
yes with uh andrew morgan yeah he was
the director
okay great you tell us what the story is
about sure
it's about a a mother an
immigrant mother living in middle
america and
on the same day she finds out that
her uh visa she's on a six-month visa
that continually gets renewed
and she finds out it's not going to be
renewed
and on the same day she finds out that
her daughter was accepted into
college but it's a it's a state school
but because she's technically not a
state resident she has to pay out of
state tuition and she just can't afford
it so she finds out all this information
on the same day
and basically has to figure out what is
she
going to do she sees the life that she
wants for her daughter and why she came
to america for it
and she sees that if she can't get her
into this school that it
might not happen and so after exhausting
all of her options she
decides that she's gonna rob a few banks
okay that's and when i
heard this story from andrew that's
where i really leaned in i was like oh
she's gonna have some bad okay that's
when i really got um
interested and we were just talking
over coffee about it we had some mutual
friends that put us together and so we
just
decided to meet up and we'd kind of
actually the meeting had been
like scheduled and then rescheduled for
like eight months
that we were planning to just meet up
and meet each other because we had some
mutual friends from
from our time in atlanta and there was
no sense of
this is going to be a job or anything
like that but i met up with andrew and
he's just telling me and he was
sort of figuring out he was debating
where to
what piece of information to lead with
does she find out that she's going to
get deported
and that's the first piece of
information or does she find out that
her
daughter got into school a really nice
uh college but can't afford it and
figure out there and we were talking
about so i sort of gave my two cents
and then a few days later he was i
really liked the way you were thinking
about my story
would you be interested in doing a
rewrite
and i said yeah that sounds cool
sorry was this based on a documentary
that he and the the actress producer
had done in the documentary it was not
based on a specific
documentary at least not to my knowledge
he
he uh was very involved in some of the
immigration issues and stuff
going on at the time and he'd also heard
a story about
a group of women in florida that were
robbing banks without guns they were
just walking up quietly and just taking
money from the tellers in a very quiet
way and he thought there was something
fascinating about that and so that's
sort of how
the the bank robberies are very low key
in
the film and he had kind of
taken some of these ideas uh and teamed
up with an actress that he knew well
and he knew could pull off this this
character because it's a lot of
it's a lot of her and a lot of her in
silence with herself which is
really tough for a
for a film to watch uh for the the
length of time that
he was thinking we'd be on her without
cuts and i was a little hesitant at
first but after seeing it on the screen
i know
he was right she's magnetic and everyone
just you could watch her
um seemingly do nothing and you
see everything going on and that's
the character and that's what they knew
and so i came in
essentially as more of like a carpenter
to help just build a few things that
they were
needed some work on and well we put the
film together
and he shot it in
[Music]
just a few weeks and i think it turned
out great and
where did you shoot it it was shot in
indiana
he found a small town that looked very
much
like the town that we were envisioning
this happening
in and he basically just leveraged
the town as his
production design and so everything you
see
in the film is was just discovered
in the town very little had to be
made and there was a lot of
value in making it real and
a place that people live and it looks
like
a place that this story would take place
and how did he know that town
i'm not sure actually okay yeah yeah
because the trailer looks beautiful and
you can see
it does seem very not rust belt but you
know you just you i'd envision a small
town and you'd set off camera that
was one where maybe a factory had closed
or people were it just
yeah the the town um the town in the
film
is uh supposed to look
just sort of in its i'd say economic
decline
and so i don't think the town he shot in
necessarily looks
exactly like the way it does in the film
but he did a good job of if it
if it was a location that looked like it
might be next on economic decline
that's the one he shot and then the
really great great one right over there
just keep that off camera and so
he did a really good job at shooting
what felt like a real town
that was a
a factory might have closed in and so he
had already written the script sorry
yeah yeah he had written i think three
drafts of the script i think
i i think was the fourth fourth draft um
and i'm not quite sure because he really
gave me a lot
of freedom to move things around in a
very
big way and that was really one of the
things that i think allowed us to
actually finish
when we did because he was already in
pre-production and there was the
shooting date already
scheduled we're going to start and there
were times when
i was writing and he was in indiana
location scouting
and i'd be writing the scene and i would
get notifications
we had a shared dropbox with the
location photos and i'd be seeing the
locations
fly in on my monitor of
the thing i was actually writing so it
was a very
quick turnaround but at the same time
there was a lot of
sort of freedom and mobility there
because i didn't have to think about a
lot of these things because it's like
you know interior laundromat i don't
have to think about what this looks like
because there's the photos like i
already know
and i already knew a lot of the pieces
and i had
the ability to move them around within
the script i just couldn't
add too much or take away too much
because cast
actors had been cast and certain
location deals had already gone through
and it just
it was going to be too much work to
pull those out find new ones and so
it's so it's like someone um
giving you an erector set
and no instructions on how to make it
but you can't
these are the pieces you have and i kind
of want it to look like this
and so andrew knew his story very well
and so we're really able to move quickly
in terms of making the screenplay
something that supported that story
because he knew it in and out
and i was able to take the screenplay
and i'd send pages every night and he'd
get back to me every morning
of yes that's great oh no this this
isn't quite gonna work because here's
why
and he was very quick with his notes and
very
succinct and spot-on and how long did
the whole rewrite process take because
you said that was his third draft when
he said it to you
yeah about five weeks
yeah we did about a week and a half
on a very rough outline making sure that
the big pieces were were there where we
wanted and he was comfortable with me
moving forward on an
outline and then once
that got the thumbs up then i had about
three and a half weeks to
do the draft and of course it's all
digital but it very much felt like
that last day of like passing but it's
like running
and it's like here's the screenplay and
someone grabs it and just like goes out
and like they were shooting it like two
days later
and it was wild i i um
i had some other stuff going on while
they were shooting so i was
uh every now and then getting like an
update from
the set or a question or two but for the
most part they took it and ran with it
and
um i trusted andrew with the story he
had been
in that world much longer than i had so
i
felt like cool they're taking care of it
and then
a couple months later he showed me a
rough cut
when he showed me the rough cut it was
it had come together
far quicker than i thought it would and
it looked fantastic i
only had two
thoughts on it i only had two notes
there was one
thing at the beginning and i said i
think this cut is just
a a frame or two too early because you
can you can hear her
breath but we're not seeing her it was
something like that um
and then at the very end there was a
shot of the
american flag and if you see if you see
the film i think
it deals with um immigration issues
and even though
the main characters
um are from another country i i feel
like
the film and i told this to andrew is
inherently american he's made a very
american film
um in my perspective
and i said i think the shot of the flag
near the end
i don't think you need it i think we
already feel this
and it feels just like one one thing too
far
and he goes i was thinking that yeah
yeah i and so we we
both notes we had we like agreed on and
he was already kind of thinking about
and i said but that's just my two cents
and if you want you know obviously
you have a vision for it i think it's
it's great he goes well no i think i
think you're right we'll
take those two things and it's pretty
close to what the
final cut is well even in the trailer
she says i can't go back
i haven't seen the film yeah i'd love to
but the trailer is excellent and she
says
i can't go back and you feel it in that
moment that there's probably many
reasons but you can tell
this is her home now she feels you know
so i don't know if the american flag was
i didn't see that part but did you feel
that it was too obvious
or yeah it was just because it was just
part of a
the shot was part of a montage
and it was just some footage that he had
picked up
throughout the town they were constantly
just shooting b-roll
and it gives the town of a real lived-in
feel and
so it was not in the script and i just
thought within this montage
all these images are specific
and feel like kind of
um that classic kind of nostalgic
feeling of america
so just to like put a shot on the flag
you just didn't need it because we were
already having
these images that were evoking america
without saying
hey did you get it by the way here's the
american flag um
and so we
we just didn't need it talking about
scripts being overwritten
it is a similar thing it's like you're
already communicating the idea
that you want to communicate you it's
not that this is changing anything it's
just you don't need it
and if you can ever simplify always
simplify
because the audience is at that point
they're just going yeah i get it move on
let's you know give me the next piece of
information
wow very cool and the film screened in
la it's screened the film premiered
in new york at hbo's new york latino
film festival
and then did a few other
festivals i was in
england at the time of the new york
premiere so i could i couldn't attend so
the first time i
saw it in in a theater with an audience
was
at the that film festival was the it was
so small but
um so like the little
after party thing i like i've never seen
so much
kind of money spent on little things
like there was a
remote control cadillac
escalade that was delivering beers oh my
goodness throughout the party
and the most bespoke uh like gelato
company presenting these things it was
it was it was crazy i
i was i felt totally out of my element
you